hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play
outlast now i've been waiting for this
game for a long time and i'm sure that
many of you
have as well it's one of the uh a really
big upcoming horror titles that's going
to be a longer let's play so get settled
in for a nice enjoyable ride i know that
says continue but i only clicked on the
new game button
uh once i have not played this at all
i've actually intentionally avoided
any sort of gameplay or trailer about
this game
outlast contains intense violence gore
graphic
sexual content and strong language
please enjoy
i think i will you are miles upshur an
investigative reporter whose ambition is
about to earn him an intimate tour of
hell on earth
always willing to risk digging into the
stories no other journalists would dare
investigate
you will seek out the dark secret of the
heart of mount massive asylum
stay alive as long as you can record
everything you are not a fighter
to navigate the horrors of mount massive
and expose the truth your only choices
are to run
hide or die i think i'll go with the run
and hide option
i tried the die option in many of the
other horror games i played
it never seems to turn out that well
mountain massive asylum so what
okay
i can barely hear that it's the radio is
kind of dulled out from everything else
box and there the radio goes
okay mount massive asylum is that where
the crazed butt stabber escaped from
i'd like to think so in fact in this
game i may encounter quite a few crazed
butt stabber
i really have been very very very
interested in playing this game because
um this game is made by a bunch of
industry professionals
uh that banded together out from aaa
game studios they banded together
because they wanted to create
a horror experience unlike any other and
um
along the same vein as some other horror
horror games you know you don't have the
option to fight and whoa hello
they're glowing 17th of september 2013.
you don't know me have to make this
quick they might be monitoring
i did two weeks of software consult at
murkoff psychiatric systems
facilities in mount massive all sorts of
ndas i am very much breaking right now
but seriously
[ __ ] those guys terrible things
happening here don't understand it don't
believe after things i saw
doctors talking about dream therapy
going too deep
finding something that had been waiting
for them in the mountain people are
being hurt murkoff is making money
it needs to be exposed if you say so
broham
i'm not entirely sure what was going on
but either way the graphics in this game
are obviously you know gonna be way
better than uh any of the indie games i
played oh i am playing through a camera
hello miles upshur
my nice press pass i have night vision
mode
okay that's pretty cool so i got a
couple tools at my disposal
especially for recording but anyway the
graphics are gonna be
very very very good because this is um
this is about as good as
indie games get in terms of development
cycles who let me
in i seem to have just waltzed in and
who closed that gate
questions questions questions okay so i
can lean to the right and the left
let's see is that tinky winky is this
slendy tubbies
no it can't be all right so i don't know
what the interact button um
press the left mouse button and open the
door slowly
so is it like oh okay so it's not quite
like amnesia
right mouse button to raise the
camcorder all right
hello all right
note to read it mount massive asylum i
start feeling sick just looking at this
place
my massive asylum shut down amid scandal
in government secrecy in 1971.
reopened by murkoff's psychiatric
systems in 2009 under the guise of a
charitable
organization cell phone reception cut
off abruptly a mile out
more like a jammer than a lost signal
the murkoff corporation has long track
record of disguising profit as charity
but never on american soil whatever they
thought they could get out of this place
has to be big
might finally be the story that breaks
the bastards all right if you say so
miles upshore okay this is
miles upshur reporting directly from
mount massive asylum
it seems to be awfully windy here i
don't need this up
i don't know if i have a battery or
something are these army vehicles
really what happened here and why is
there nobody nearby and why am i just
waltzing in you'd think there'd be some
sort of security
oh wait demonic horrific investiga
infestation i mean not investigation
hello
bing bong delivery
okay so i'm assuming that i gotta find
another way around
hello this seems to be like a suitable
location i don't know if i have
indefinite sprint
okay that's locked up definitely not can
i jump okay i can jump
forward but not up just gonna bunny hop
my way over here
hello hmm i do believe this gate is
locked
okay so there's gotta be something
around here like a cellar door
it makes sense that i would come into a
horror game and especially a
mental institution through the
cellar ah here we go
teach me how to crouch at the same time
get all the tutorials out of the way i
gotta say i'm very
impressed with the graphics right now
it's very nicely well done
superb okay can i go in here hello
yes oh come on
can i bash it down nope jiggly jiggly
alright so that was a negatory
i thought it was guiding me the right
way to go with the light but i see a
window up there that i'm gonna try to
get up
ladder see you can zoom in and out with
the mouse wheel
yeah i see that what
did i just pee my pants oh okay i just i
was okay
hang on there don't go crazy just yet
um obviously in the beginning of these
of these uh horror game it spends a lot
of time setting the tone
for what the game is gonna be you can
actually pick up a lot of foreshadowing
throughout the game in the beginning of
the game if you go back to amnesia
there's actually quite a bit of
foreshadowing throughout the game that's
uh pretty interesting to what it's going
to be uh oh
well that's the start of something bad
what is this this is that movie i didn't
see the movie but you remember the movie
outbreak or
containment or i forget what it's called
oh this is gonna be good haunted plant
i can feel the leaves
okay i've actually got a cool timer that
says exactly how long i've been
recording
for see i can turn that off right
so since i am an investigative reporter
i whoa what did i just do
hello decided to caress the edge of this
wall for a second there
hmm peeking out ever so closely
investigative reporter marshall
upshur i forget what my name was
okay what was that was that the tv
why did the tv do that what was on that
there's something on that
oh no assistant
hello why you be doing that
okay anyway i'm just gonna keep the
oh okay so i do sort of move it with my
body
all right squeeze through the gap
this is gonna be good i already see
blood on the walls which is definitely
a good sign can i hack into these
computer systems
ah battery cool wonder why the infrared
light needs separate batteries but it's
an interesting mechanic
say what are you doing there hey
what's going on okay so i only have a
very specific amount of
battery for the uh infrared light i need
to just take that cautiously
who's there collected documents let's
read
project wall rider billy yeah
patient billy awesome dr carl houston
patient claims you have progressed to
self-directed lucid dream states
morphogenic engine activity observed at
unprecedented scale
continuing stage four homeowners hormone
hormone schedule spirometry revealed no
bronchial accumulation
hematocrit centrifuge again again failed
to separate
erythrocytes highly worrisome mri
revealed arrhythm
arithmetic rem
nrem cycle laughter in nrem state
interview notes billy asked about the
status of his mother's lawsuit against
murkoff on the asylum this represents
catastrophic breach and security despite
billy's claim that he discovered the
truth
in the blood dreams of dr trager hold
the only trigger on company records one
richard trigger is an executive
executive from mrd all orderly and
security personnel must be questioned
and video securities improved
to include analytic biometrics all right
oh hello that was a bit of a mouthful
there
but i got through it nonetheless i'm
hoping that my narrative reading style
will be oh sorry does someone want some
privacy in the bathroom
too bad i'm a coming in excuse me
are you tinkling in there i gotta use a
bathroom okay nevermind
ooh cola my favey
oh right then that's not a good sign
so either someone was going in or coming
out
let's see what does this say roe king
forbid juden hello got another battery i
see a little bar in the
four of ten okay whatever no time for
that
no time to go to the bathroom either oh
hello wait there we go
okay so i can't i can't open anything
okay let me put down my camera for a
second there
okay seems like that whoa are those
intestines
what someone is having nice intestine
and cola snack
the tasty treat that can't be beat okay
i'm guessing i'd go up here
yeah great idea let's go in the vent
where there was blood
investigative journalism at its best
oh hey oh i'm sorry were you the guy
that i was barging into the bathroom
from
with maybe he was coming to collect me
he wanted me to join him or hold his
hand
or wipe his butt for him i'm good at
that
professional butt wiper before i did
youtube
let's see
what was that what the hell was that
what did you just throw at me
i wasn't ready for that jesus calm down
okay so is it dead body a headless dead
body
all right and there's another dead body
it
is also headless ah that's fantastic
good great good great
all right so this is how this game's
gonna be
oh that's so creepy
is that a thing full of heads
okay oh maybe at this point i would like
to dive out the window and
run
they killed us she got out
the very okay you can't fight
to die them think i'll do that unlock
the main doors
for the security control if you say so
and now you're going to promptly die you
have to
oh no not yet out of this terrible way
i'm gonna take your advice
and that window right there i'm gonna
come crashing through that is a large
collection of heads
wow okay i'm running out of battery i
gotta keep moving oh
that guy was like in full body armor
where they kill them
thanks for the warning bro okay
no no not in the door close the door
close the damn door
i'm pressing the left mouse button okay
fine you know what
we're gonna turn that off
we're gonna creep along ever so
gently until we find whatever the freak
of frack i'm looking for
hello watch out for me i'm an
investigative reporter
i got a cam recorder camera recorder
camcorder
okay it's awfully bright
hi who are you then mike upshur
investigative reporter how you doing oh
me i'm markiplier
good to see you i i see
merciful god you have sent me an apostle
guard your life son you have a calling
do i does that calling include insanity
and death
because that seems to be what happens in
this place
so that was some sort of priest was that
the guy from that painting i saw a
painting when i first entered the
building of a guy
who looked like some sort of a priest
that might have been that guy
escape the asylum is my very first
objective
great idea this guy finally has the
right idea even though he didn't go
backwards but i guess he dropped down
that vent so he couldn't
so yeah what is with this place in
collecting people's heads
the dissevered heads left and right this
isn't good
that's not good and then guys excuse me
sir you seem to have dropped your
intestines all over the floor
you gonna pick those up oh you're just
gonna leave it for the janitor what a
douche all right okay
so this did you give me okay he didn't i
thought he took
my camera for a second there let's see
are you dead
are you actually dead you seem to still
have your head so i'm gonna assume that
you're not dead until you look like
you're dead
maybe i'll just put you to bed
man what how the heck the heck
did this all happen i don't even want to
know
i don't even want to know okay so anyway
that was a bit of a heart attack to
start the game off
i am officially out of time for this
part but expect a lot more i'm going to
be doing this series
a lot a lot up in the coming
things i might even go up to uh three
videos a day is that my blood okay
that's not bad
so this is going to be an absolutely
incredible game proclaim the gospel
this is absolutely going to be an
incredible game i can already tell it's
going to be absolutely phenomenal
i'm so excited to play it so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that i've
done
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
finally back into the gameplay i wanted
to say that i'm not going to be
interrupting
any of the cutscenes like i'm going to
try to stay out of the story as much as
possible because
me as a let's player i'm just doing
commentary here on this game but the
story is so important
in a lot of ways i felt like a camera
man
now i think we're finally getting into
things there might be more